Speaker 1: George
Santos is the Republican elect, congressman
elect, becoming congressman now, presumably
from representing New York, who lied about
his employment history.
He lied about his educational history.
He lied about his Jewish background, which
seems to be imaginary.
He's under.
U.S. criminal investigation, Brazil is criminally
investigating him, etc., etc..
He had quite a day in Washington, D.C.
You've got to see this stuff first in an effort
to avoid having to talk to any media.
He just kind of did this thing where he walks
quickly and tries to get away from reporters.
He ended up walking into the dead end of a
basement hallway in the Longworth House Office
Building while trying to get away from reporters.
You've got to see this stuff.
Speaker 2: Yes, I am.
These two senators tend to serve both years
of your term.
Speaker 4: Over the speaker.
Speaker 1: Not taking any questions, by the.
Speaker 2: Way.
And tell us if you plan to serve both years
of your term, Mr. Sanchez, will you answer
any question besides, will you support Leader
McCarthy to be speaker?
You speak to any of the concerns about your
biography, what you tell folks about your
background.
Oh, my good.
Republican leadership told you anything, Mr.
Sanders table.
Speaker 4: That you would like to clear up
or explain about the war in Iraq.
Speaker 1: All right.
So hitting a dead end there and having to
turn around and then it gets even more awkward.
Lately, Ibsen tried asking him some questions
when he first showed up yesterday.
He also didn't want to answer those constituents.
Speaker 4: Do you feel like you're qualified
to serve in this Congress right now?
Speaker 1: By the way, the backpack I know.
Speaker 4: How do you hope your constituents
can trust you even though that you've misrepresented
your biography?
Speaker 2: What's your response to calls for
a House ethics investigation by the good guys?
Guys?
Do you have.
Speaker 4: Any statements about your campaign
and how you hope to govern?
Speaker 2: Now.
Speaker 1: The mere I love the question.
This guy is not going to govern.
Are you nuts?
It's a funny question in that he's obviously
not going to do any governing.
Speaker 4: To carry out your full term.
Speaker 2: What can you say to reassure your
constituents that you'll do what you said
you were going to do?
Speaker 1: All right.
You get the point.
Walking Miles, seemingly avoiding questions
from reporters.
I don't know how tenable it's going to be
for him to just never answer questions.
Then we get to him sitting in the House chamber
and you almost start to feel bad for him,
except that you don't, as proceedings were
going on, just sitting by himself on his phone
and we have video of it right now that we're
showing you, sitting by himself, looking dejected,
sulking in the House chamber on his phone
and just nobody talking to him.
You let me know whether you feel bad.
I mean, listen, he he lied about everything,
you know, this guy really, really did lie
about everything.
And now, I mean, listen, it's not like Republicans
are honest.
It's not like I have a delusion that the reason
Republicans are shunning him is because they're
honest and this guy is dishonest.
Obviously, that's not the case.
But it is just funny and kind of like weird
to see there.
He is picking his nose and we'll actually
look at that moment a little more closely.
That was a much scrutinized moment, almost
like the Zapruder film.
You will see here that he does an interesting
move as he sits there where he goes in for
the pic and then very casually does a sort
of rolling motion, does a kind of a rolling
motion, and he does seem to be able to dislodge
the mucus that he was able to obtain there.
And then lastly, when this was all said and
done, Jorge Santos attempting to leave the
Capitol again, sort of disoriented and not
taking any questions from Caitlin Weyburn.
Speaker 4: From CBS News.
Can you tell us how your first day with Congressman
Santos.
Speaker 2: Worked for me?
Speaker 1: He really does look like a lost
kid on the first day of camp with the backpack
and everything and just its bizarre imagery.
Unidentified: I really want to go to New Orleans.
Speaker 1: It's like, how the hell do I get
out of here?
Speaker 3: Can you tell us how your first
day was?
Speaker 1: No.
Well, nobody talked to me, and the kids were
mean.
Speaker 4: Do you have anything to say about
all of the allegations?
I can you?
Are you confident that you'll be sworn in?
Speaker 1: Yes.
And off he goes into The Dark Knight, ultimately
finding an elevator that would eventually
take him outside.
This doesn't seem at all sustainable.
And one would imagine at some point if George
Santos is actually going to serve, he's going
to have to answer questions from someone.
And there have to be real questions, not like
those softball interviews that we looked at
last week.
So a tough first day at school, at work.
Sorry for Jorge Santos.
Unclear whether he had those Capri Sun juice
pouches in his backpack or what, but not going
well.
And we will see what happens today.
Nothing definitive, by the way, as to whether
there was any kind of quid pro quo between
Santos and Kevin McCarthy.
The, of course, speculated quid pro quo would
be McCarthy supports Santos, not resigning
and being sworn in.
Santos pledges to vote for McCarthy for speaker
of the House and all day.
Amidst all those questions, the one thing
that McCarthy, rather, that Santos did answer
is that, yes, he will be supporting Kevin.
Kevin McCarthy for speaker, if you've just
been listening today and you're curious about
the visual component for these things they've
played.
Check them out on our Instagram, which you
can find it David Pakman show.
And of course, we'll also have all of these
clips on our YouTube channel.
Make sure you were subscribed to the big,
very big YouTube channel, YouTube.com slash
The David
Pakman Show.